-Welcome back!
-How are you, man?
-I'm great.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thank you.
-This movie is very cool
in that it basically -- most
of it takes place on a train.
-On a train, yes.
-And yet it's an action movie.
-Yes.
-And there are many action
sequences on the train.
-On the train.
-Including -- you have
a fight scene in a train car.
-There's are many
fight scenes...
-Yeah.
-...in said train car.
-And what's crazy is there
is only one train car.
-Oh.
-That's not even a punch line.
Literally,
we shot it on a stage
in Pinewood in England.
And you have to build
a whole train.
But they literally
just did one car
and then they'd swap everybody
out and put in more background
and then shoot the next scene.
I don't know how the director
did it.
-The funny thing is,
no matter how many times
you go on a movie set,
like, I'm sure you thought,
"Great,
I'll be on a whole train."
-Yeah, no.
-They're like, no,
that's not how movies work.
-One car.
-We're just gonna use one car.
-I imagine there is an amazing
amount of choreography
to a fight scene that takes
place in a closed space.
-Yeah, it is, definitely.
And one, you don't want to
hurt people.
-Yes.
-Because it's also,
like, real seats.
And, you know, trains aren't
the most comfortable of spaces.
-Yeah.
-There's a lot of metal around.
-And to shoot it
in such a different way
to make each fight interesting,
is also --
-Right. Of course.
It's like, "Oh, another
train fight, great."
[ Laughter ]
You've worked with Liam before.
-I have.
-You were in "A-Team."
-We have fought before.
-Oh, you fought in "A-Team."
-Yes.
-You had a fight
with Liam Neeson?
-Yes, yes I did.
-How is he?
Is he one of the guys --
-Large.
-He's a large man.
He is a large man.
He is surprisingly --
I mean, I know he looks --
-He's a giant.
-He's one of those guys
that looks big in movies
and then is somehow even bigger
in real life.
-Yeah, he's like 7'3".
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and is he a guy
who swaps out for
his stunt double
when it comes time for fights?
-His stunt double is very short.
So it's very --
-It's very hard, yeah.
-No, he will -- he'll go for it.
-Okay.
-In fact,
I remember this on "A-Team."
The stunt double usually comes
up after a take and says,
"You know what? You can give it
to him a little more."
'Cause you don't wanna --
you know, it's Liam Neeson.
I mean, I know he does this
a lot, but you know,
you respect the guy.
-Sure, of course.
-You don't want to
sort of go at it.
And then the stunt double
comes up and says,
"Give it to him."
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, he can take it.
-All right.
Well I mean, I believe
he can take it.
I would be more worried
about you.
Don't take it the wrong way.
[ Laughter ]
You have another --
-I gotta go.
-I'm assuming there's plenty
of stunts in --
You're doing "Aquaman."
-I am.
-You filmed "Aquaman"
for six months.
-Another large man.
Well, that's even --
Jason Momoa.
-Yes, yes.
-He must be 7'5".
-He is, he's like 8'2".
[ Laughter ]
-Because it's great,
because when those --
when you watch the movie,
you're like,
"I wonder who is going to
win the fight,
Jason Momoa or Patrick Wilson?"
[ Laughs ]
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-You're killing me.
-You play -- Tell me --
Look, I --
You'd beat me in a fight.
[ Laughter ]
You play Aquaman's half-brother.
-Yes. The smaller, shorter...
-Orm.
-...whiter half.
-Your name is Orm?
-My name is Orm.
-That's great.
-I'm a badass in that movie.
-Yeah, no.
-He's the Ocean Master.
-Orm sounds like a guy
you would be scared by.
[ Laughter ]
"Guys, look out, Orm is coming!"
-Hey, guys!
You know what's funny?
We would, on my chair --
'cause the chair in the
movie -- I don't know why
I'm referring to the chair.
But it would say "Orm."
And we'd put tape
so it says "Norm."
Which made me even less --
-When you go under water,
you would drop the "N."
-That's right.